a flight right up to the General's
Palace I drop it at his feet I'm like
boom you looking for this
[Music]
what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today we have some
really really big and great news a lot
of us were concerned when Marvel Studios
revealed all of phase five and some of
phase six and we didn't see armor Wars
anywhere on the slates this was
particularly concerning considering the
fact that Marvel Studios had already
announced armor Wars told us kind of
what the plot was going to be about and
of course confirmed Don cheadle's
involvement so we were worried that it
might be canceled since we didn't see it
anywhere on Phase 5 or on phase six but
it looks like the reason it was not
revealed on either is because Marvel
Studios is now developing it into a
movie rather than a series on Disney
plus and this is really great news one
because I personally prefer movies I do
like the Disney plus format but to me
you really just can't beat a movie a
theater experience watching it on the
big screen it's the best best to me two
Roadie gets his own movie we finally get
a movie focused on War Machine and three
this allows the movie to be bigger
movies get more of a budget they get
more time focused on them and I think a
lot of people will agree that some of
the Disney Plus shows things like the
CGI aren't that great but with a movie
they put more time More Money More
tension into it so I have no doubt that
armor Wars will be better as a movie
than it would be as a Disney Plus show
now this report today is coming from The
Hollywood Reporter and we'll go over it
and talk about what it means also if
you're new be sure to hit that subscribe
button and hit the notification Bell
because we talk about the MCU every day
so let's just go right into the article
by The Hollywood Reporter the headline
reads Marvel shakes up armor Wars Don
Cheadle series now being developed as a
movie and this is a Hollywood Reporter
exclusive now the first thing it says is
Yasser Lester who was acting as head
writer on the series will remain as its
feature scribe meaning he's going to
continue to write the movie now the
article reads Marvel Studios has shaken
up its arm rewards project and now what
was to have been a series for Disney
plus will be redeveloped as a feature
film now here comes some important
information it says the move essentially
pushes back the title further down the
development slate sources say the studio
was committed in getting the story told
the right way and in that process
realized that a feature was better
suited for the project I want to pause
right here and take a second to
appreciate this decision Marvel Studios
was moving forward with this project and
as they were developing it decided that
a Disney plus series was not the right
move and instead of continuing and
saying well we kind of already started
the development of this series already
we've planned it out we have people in
place we can't turn back now they
decided no we are indeed going to switch
things up and do what is best for the
project this is a great move in kudos to
Marvel for making it and I think it
might put fans at ease some who have
been thinking lately well Marvel Studios
really isn't putting that much time into
some projects that have been coming out
on Disney plus this is a great
confirmation that they are they are
putting time and effort into the Disney
Plus shows and they're just putting time
and effort into projects in general and
deciding what is right for them now the
article continues by saying Marvel had
been eyeing a 2023 start of production
on the series but the few people who
were gearing up for that were notified
Thursday of the change of Direction no
directors have been officially attached
and it is unclear when an armor Wars
feature would pop up on Marvel's
timeline of its phase of movies and
Disney plus Series so essentially what
this means is armor Wars was going to
start in 2023 most likely coming out in
2024 but now that it's a movie this is
most likely pushed back and production
might not start until 2024 and the movie
might not come out until 2025. so it is
looking like this is probably going to
be a phase six film I would be shocked
if they waited until after phase six I'm
sure they want to get this movie out
before Secret Wars because I'm sure
rhodian War Machine are going to play a
significant part in that so right now I
think we can expect a 2025 release date
probably early to mid 2025 the only
projects that we know are coming in 2025
right now are the Avengers the King
Dynasty and Avengers Secret Wars so
again I would expect a 2025 release date
for the armor Wars movie now not a
Disney Plus show but a movie this is
exciting news I'm excited that it is
going to be a movie I think it's going
to be better but let me know what you
think about this in the comments down
below be sure to let me know don't
forget to like the video and of course
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest MCU news for live updates
you can follow me on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof